chacun à sa passion les films la danse
le chant le sport obama a osé compris ma
passion c'est le football pas vrai plus
jeune j'ai touché à tout ce qui touchait
de près ou de loin au dessin la bd de
l'acrylique d'ukraine couleurs des lois
civiles des bougeoirs dont les photos
sur des cascades des papes vers toys d
art toys des stickers des découpages
rappelé qu'il y avait un endroit vide il
fallait que je le comble a eu les
dessins et des patients que tu peux
partager latence à plusieurs c'est bien
le football à plusieurs c'est mieux le
dessin à plusieurs c'est pas aux
leersois rejoue la fenêtre et un pigeon
qui rentre juste je suis un montage tout
me déconcentre c'est incapable de
travailler individuellement mais en
groupe ça me fait plaisir de vous
inviter le bon bah je me rends compte
j'adore dessiner mais je le sais c'est
pas une passion qui est très wa houwa
est comme ça face à ta feuille pas une
passion qui va t'aider à pécho par
exemple il ya des passions qui marche
beaucoup mieux pour ça 45 minutes plus
tard écoute cet ennui si je couche avec
le mec là bas non non pas de souci je
passe à l'encrassement wim album regarde
moi bien d'un vieux je connais pas le
dessin c'est une passion qui peut
arriver super tôt à tous les gamins ont
pris des crayola pour gribouiller sur
des feuilles du coup face à des passions
du genre le bricolage le saut en
parachute qui font vraiment très adulte
le dessin ça fait assez
enfantin à la politique je peux en
parler pendant des heures ah oui la
politique c'est ma passion des toits
cyprien quelle est ta passion le dessin
le dessein a dit oui le dessin mais
j'aime aussi la politique il ne répond
pas aux adultes c'est vrai j'aime bien
la police vient tu file dans ta chambre
quel gâchis bon comme je dessine tout le
temps j'ai pris l'option arts plastiques
au lycée et j'ai croisé de tous les gens
dans ma classe 1 ce qui dessine des
bonhommes voilà j'en fais partie ceux
qui sont un petit peu plus poussée qui
vont faire des petites peintures à
l'huile tout ça est ce qu on a
totalement perdu
est ce un pâté dessin mais moi j'ai
trouvé une grosse branche de bois dans
la forêt je vais coller des bouts de
verre et du métal et des yeux découpées
dans des magazines dessus pour faire une
oeuvre comme ça qu'ils dénoncent
l'impact de l'homme sur l'écologie et ça
tu peux pas comprendre c'est un truc de
wight doit céder bonhomme tous les ans
dans ma classe j'ai eu un mec qui a fait
une peinture avec son propre sang c'est
pour mettre de la souffrance dans mon
oeuvre on peut mettre une part de
moi-même mon adn c'est pour chercher la
vérité dans le mensonge
ils se sont coupés pour finalement faire
une peinture marron parce que oui on le
sent sur du papier ça devient marron les
couleurs sont fades parce que c'est
extrêmement liquides
ça pue et c'est extrêmement dangereux
top idée archibald nous a quittés
tragiquement après avoir contracté le
tétanos suite à une coupure non
maîtrisée il a eu 11 sur 20 ju son prof
au téléphone les couleurs sont fades et
ça pue dans la classe repose en paix à
mme chibane c'est important d'avoir la
vie des autres sur ses dessins des
compliments comme des critiques
positives ou négatives et puis parfois
tu as des phrases tu sais pas trop
comment
les prendre franchement tu as trop de la
chance de bien savoir dessiner bas merci
oui oui oui jedessine et toi je sais pas
toi je veux pas non plus vian fait un
bonhomme enfin voudrait et en prenant
enfin juste deux ans j'ai trop de 7,4
avons eu de la chance avec le plus
chanceux sur terre il s'agit il s'agit
clairement de change à vous nous les
dessinateurs en un petit hic énervant
quand les gens cherchent un jeu tous été
on propose toujours un pictionnary voilà
je le confesse je suis désolé guy un
legging un iphone un mais on s'est fini
c'est dommage domalain annonce avoir un
chat dans la gorge ça c'est pas clair
pas de monter sur ses grands chevaux
belle et vous savez quoi on va faire un
monopoly qu'on t'a dit pictionary offert
beach volley sur sa luge bien à la
tecktonik ils veulent il m'a aidé en
terre chaise
non non non parce que peut pas ne peut
pas dire c'est une chaise dissoudre
l'assemblée nationale
oui n'empêche tout le monde a déjà
dessiné au moins une fois dans sa vie au
moins quand tu es gamin avec des crayons
de couleurs fallait pas débordé je
dirais même que ceux de ma génération on
a tous dessinés au moins deux fois dans
sa vie une fois quand tu es gamin et une
fois quand tu as eu ton premier
ordinateur et à mon fils je t'ai acheter
un ordinateur personnel au regard et à
peine
donc ça le dessin numérique et ben c'est
vraiment de la merde mais nous ramène au
magasin non c'est l'un des saints c'est
une passion qui est assez dur pour en
faire son métier voilà il faut beaucoup
de travail beaucoup de persévérance pour
réussir à vivre de la bd du graphisme et
puis il ya des métiers où il ya du
dessin mais par contre on oublie la
passion il avait aussi un visage un peu
carré il portait un bonnet et il avait
des cheveux courts blonds qui s'est mal
terminé son portrait robot
j'adore le manga voilà ça m'a fait
plaisir de vous parler de ma passion et
aussi voulu en savoir plus sur le dessin
j'ai fait une petite vidéo bonus en lien
à la fin de la vidéo dans la description
que donne des petites astuces pour
dessiner ses cadeaux et on n'a pas
oublié l'objectif 10 millions d'abonnés
on arrive très très bientôt aux 10
millions d'abonnés on devrait vous avez
déjà dépassé les 10 millions d'abonnés
merci beaucoup c'est arrivé beaucoup
trop vite fait et je vous prépare une
vidéo spéciale pour ça alors vous dis à
très vite sur internet
[Musique]
tous
je suis fichu